how's it going everybody it's Warren and
an Avengers end game we watched the
Avengers go back in time collect the
Infinity stones come back to the present
time and perform a snap that brought
everybody back to life however that is
not where it ended after the Avengers
defeated Thanos they needed to take the
Infinity stones back to each point in
time to where they took it from this was
a promise that Bruce Banner made to the
ancient one in order to avoid creating
alternate timelines at the end of the
movie we found out that Captain America
was going to be the one to bring all of
the stones back to their original points
in time and that he did it successfully
and soon after the movie everybody
started to realize that Captain America
would have had to return the soul stone
to Red Skull this obviously raised a lot
of questions on how this interaction
would go down but luckily for us the
rooster brothers were asked this in a
Q&A and have cleared some things up for
us we also found out what happens to the
souls that were sacrificed when the soul
stone is returned I'll break down what
they said in this video but first be
sure to subscribe to my channel at the
400,000 subscriber mark I'll be giving
away three Marvel legend series
collection items so in a recent Q&A in
China the Russo brothers were asked how
the interaction between Captain America
and Red Skull would go down when Captain
America went to return the soul stone
and as it turns out and may not be
exactly what you think here's what the
Russo brothers had to say in response to
the question
red skull would probably put the soul
stone back to his location and wait for
the next unfortunate stone seeker to
make sacrifice cap and red skull
probably won't fight it's because it's
his mission to return the stone to its
original place the Red Skull is also no
longer the same red skull from the First
Avenger he is more like a ghost you
could almost say he's a completely
different entity now he only exists to
guard the stone his past conscious may
or may not exist any more so according
to the Russo brothers there really
wouldn't be any much of a reaction
between the two of them captain's job is
to return the stone and red skulls job
is to guard the stone and from what it
sounds like this red skull is a
completely different red skull than we
saw in the first avenger with the Russo
brothers saying that his conscious may
not even exist but if it does he only
cares about guarding the stone not about
what happened in the past with Captain
America but like I said we also found
out what happened to the soul that was
sacrif
to get the soul stone when the soul
stone is put back in a separate
interview with comicbook.com Christopher
Markus who was one of the writers for
Avengers infinity war and Avengers and
game commented on the matter as well and
he said I do know that there are no give
backs it's not a pawn shop you don't get
the soul back when you get the stone
back you're welcome to give the stone
back but it's an everlasting exchange so
just because you return the stone does
not mean that the soul you sacrifice to
get the stone is returned to you
according to the writers of infinity war
and in game once you sacrifice the soul
the soul is gone forever so sadly it
doesn't seem like we're going to
beginning back gomorrah or black widow
anytime soon if at all but there you
have it that is what happened when
Captain America returned the soul stone
to red skull captain simply did his job
by returning the soul stone and red
skull simply did his job by taking it
back and protecting it until the next
person came to make a sacrifice and
sadly when the soul stone was returned
Natasha did not come back to life and
this is coming directly from the
directors and the writers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers and game
themselves so let me know what you think
about what they said in the interviews
and another reminder to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway at
the 400,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and they will each
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection to enter be
sure to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain and I'll post more about the
giveaway later on as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]